MARK MIRCHANDANI:
On this episode,
we talk to doc.ai
about how they're
bringing the power
to the people when
it comes to medical research.
Akshay, thank you so
much for joining us.
Can you tell us a little bit
more about what doc.ai is?
AKSHAY SHARMA: First of all,
thank you for having me.
Happy to share what doc.ai is.
So doc.ai is a
digital health company
designed for a new generation
of medical research.
And what it really
means is that today,
the world of medical research is
very localized to your doctors
deciding where you, the
patient, should be ushered
into for clinical trials
or what type of drugs
that you should be on.
So what we are seeing is that
patients and general users
aren't involved in the
world of medical research.
They don't have agency
to make decisions.
So with doc.ai, we are
building a bunch of ecosystems
of tools, including a doc.ai
companion medical research app,
but also, other tools
and technologies
using artificial
intelligence that
allows patients to take
ownership of their own data
and also be able to decide
what type of medical research
that they want to participate
in, all through the mobile app.
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
So you mentioned AI.
What aspect of AI
are you bringing
to the users who are using
the doc.ai's platform?
AKSHAY SHARMA: It's
a great question.
So I think what we care
about is, how can users
collect medical signals
and medical information
and capture all of this
data on their mobile phone,
using their mobile phone?
So what that means
is that we can
use different components of
a phone like, for example,
your camera, but
also your voice, also
things like chat bots.
So we invest in a lot of
tools and technologies
that help us roll out different
AI components for data capture.
We are also
investing quite a bit
in privacy and
security-preserving tools
and technologies, like
Federated Learning,
along with
differential privacy so
that we can keep the
data on the phone
but still use the
to train models that can
give a global perspective
of the population without
actually ever sending
the data to a server.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: So that's
a lot of different pieces
that you're covering
as a company.
How does this relate to
health care as an industry?
AKSHAY SHARMA: Right.
So I think what we see
with health care is
that, without members and
participants being part
of the health care,
we are not going
to get enough information
about the progression
of different diseases or we
are not going to make progress
in terms of research.
So an important
aspect of health care
is, how do we get patients and
users involved in research?
So one aspect of this
is data collection.
So with the doc.ai medical
app, what we have built
is a multiomics or polyomics
way of collecting data.
So examples of that is we could
collect your genomics data
and keep the data on the phone.
We can collect your medical
records, your pharmacy records,
your medication pill
bottles, your lab records,
but also newer types of
information, like how
about your location and how
does that impact your health?
We call it exposomics.
So all we need is
your GPS location.
We can keep that on the
phone for you if you want
and still be able to
understand your health.
So we invest quite a bit
in different and new types
of data collection through
consumer remediation.
On the other side,
what we want to do
is be able to get
all of this data
through the right consent
and opt-in and correlate
information across
different types of data.
So we call it the polyomics
data combination problem.
So be able to understand,
how does your genomics
information influence
based on where you live?
So I think this will change
the way it influences
health care for other
players in the ecosystem
by having wider adoption
of participants and members
and patients being more
involved in research.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Stay tuned
for more great conversations
with doc.ai.
If you enjoyed this episode,
check out the Stack Chat
playlist for more great videos.
[MUSIC PLAYING]